Trump
well that's happened in the last 10
years
it's a miracle I'm even sitting here now
I got a second chance
I'm going to take advantage of that
but I need you with me Pete
we're gonna Heal the World
guys this is my best friend Harry hey
good to meet you good job huh
still gonna have time for tutoring we'll
figure it out
I didn't know there were bears in these
Woods
AMJ I have another name for you Craven
he's here on some kind of hunt
I'm just a call away
you don't know what you took for me
all miles talks about is how to be a
better Spider-Man
you what the hell is going on with me
he's not himself go help him
this was our dream
we're going to kill the world
[Music]